ryan giggs arrived for the second day of
his trial to hear the woman he's accused
of assaulting describe in graphic detail
the events of that night in november
2020. kate gravel said she'd already
decided to end her relationship with the
former footballer for good when another
argument began during a night out in
manchester
when she returned to the home they
shared to pack up her belongings he
followed and a struggle began he pushed
her backwards she told the jury and
pinned her to the floor he pushed her
head into the ground she thought he'd
broken her elbow
that's when he came up to my face and
head butted me she said he came at me
from nowhere grabbed me by the shoulders
and head butted me in the face i said i
can't believe you've just done that i
was in shock and fell backwards my lip
instantly swelled so i put my hands over
my mouth and i was really worried
because i could taste the blood and
thought he'd split my lip open
all the other times he'd hurt me this
was different he really wanted to hurt
me he looked me straight in the eyes and
headbutted me when she wanted to call
the police he said you need to think
about this kate it will ruin me and ruin
you he was saying think about my job
think about my career think about my
kids and i said then you shouldn't have
done it earlier the court had been
played kate grevel's police interview
from the time in which she described a
number of incidents over the years in
one she said mr giggs had grabbed her
wrists and dragged her naked out of a
hotel room in another he kicked her so
hard in the back she flew off a bed he
then threw a bag containing a laptop at
her head leaving her she said crying her
eyes out on the floor the jury was shown
a number of images of injuries alleged
to have been caused by mr giggs
she said at the start of their
relationship she thought ryan giggs was
her soul mate it was the best thing ever
she said a love story like in the movies
but she was already seeing what she
called red flags abusive messages and
threats to reveal things about their
relationship
ryan giggs left court having heard his
former girlfriend say she felt isolated
and helpless in their relationship and
that that's why she went back to him he
denies the charges against him her
evidence continues greg milam sky news
manchester